[Music]
what's your question
shoot Wow
what a question I was not expecting that
okay what was an ziyan one go I've
developed more character more of myself
basically you develop an identity when
you start to experience life and go
through things that test you well [ __ ]
in every [ __ ] way like I I started
with deep depression and was suicidal
and so I pushed everyone away and I set
my life on fire and then I did a yoga
teacher training and I'm all about self
therapy and self healing I've come such
a long way too like selfish victim poor
me too like I [ __ ] rock I'm in
control of my life and I'm grateful for
Who I am right now
and that is up dramatically I was a
small town and
outside of Austin Texas most of my
family is out extremely conservative
eyelid here in San Diego I am married to
my wife who is from Pakistan
and I am
[Music]
so I have changed dramatically in lots
of ways but more I think the way I've
changed the most is my mind has been
open to the world around me and I'm more
embracing
of all cultures
[Music]
I'm not as crazy anymore
and I don't do drugs
stop doing drugs and then well back in
it's pretty hard to answer that
I love it use
I guess I would changed most in the last
India I would hope so
you'd hope you have it King yeah yeah I
just like the way I am I guess become
less horny I stepped more into my more
authentic self especially in terms of
wearing my natural hair my natural skin
just being my natural self I went from
being pretty homegrown Iowan to being
pretty freewheeling cosmopolitan
I would have to say I've gotten a lot
stronger before like seven years ago I
hated God I hated the Christian faith
and thought it was stupid and but when I
really don't even to it and just really
took Jesus Christ as who he says he was
in the Bible he met me in a really real
way and he has transformed my life
and uh and so yeah that's the answer
not religious anymore that's probably
how I changed
being able to let go of things that
better lives that I need to I guess you
know
he's my son
[Music]
I think I've just learned how to
trust my instincts a little bit more and
go with the flow just a little bit more
I changed the most in the best two years
because I moved to America and now I
actually tried to make all my dreams
come true and work for what I want in
life
Wow
certainly I think about at least two
other people first now and my wife who
should be coming up in a moment so it's
not just me anymore it's kids first and
wife then
I've become more open emotionally and I
think that's helped me grow as a person
I probably love my parents like a lot
more I used to fight with my mom it was
time but I actually like appreciate my
parents and like love everything they'd
give it to me so I think I'm just more
grateful person probably become less shy
more outspoken I think I became more
mature how I interact with other people
I guess and hug them more on a positive
manner instead of a negative way it'd be
hard to pick one thing but I I think
that I've become focused on myself in a
healthy way in that I mean finding what
I really enjoy doing because I feel like
through that process I've determined or
really my intention and purposes for how
I want to spend my days right now I am
doing what I call free listening and
it's simply just a display that I set up
I have a sign that says literally that
sometimes the stranger can be easier to
open up to the new closest love home
just growth I mean I don't know I can't
like pinpoint one certain thing but I
think I just matured a lot like as far
as being becoming a man and
understanding what being a man is about
gotten a little wiser I think I got a
little funny it's really learning and
understanding who I am and being okay
with that and accepting it grew up but
not too much I've become less social
with people
oh no I'm just becoming more holistic
person I changed my diet to eliminate
cruelty I'm vegan I think sustainability
is just become a big part of who I am
and so my live change too much like
moved to United States what's so hard
for me so complicated and and I think my
name is angel so where you from I'm from
Mexico well I've changed since I was
five because I've been there learning
English my whole life I think and in the
last five years I was in TJ living with
my mom by ourselves and then my dad
moved in and then we and then now we're
all a family here
[Music]
okay your English is so good you know
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]